I didn't cry at the end of Toy Story 3
just throwing that out there
I know it seems strange to bring up but
with the way people react to this film
especially the ending uh I just felt
that be an important thing to hear
before you listen to the rest of us
with that said Toy Story 3 the final in
the Toy Story trilogy everyone went nuts
for this movie they said it was
emotional they said it was funny they
said to one's dog they said was creative
blah blah blah they went crazy for it I
think it's good yeah it's good ok ok was
just going to the story
Andy who's now going to college has to
make a decision about whether or not he
still wants to hold on to his toys the
toys well aware this have to make a
decision whether or not they want to
hold on to Andy well after a
miscommunication they figure that the
best thing to do is probably to move on
they make their way to a daycare center
where they figure they can be enjoyed by
children for years and years to come
the only problem is the toy running the
daycare center seems to be a
power-hungry control freak who puts the
toys in with kids who are not the
appropriate age to be playing with when
they tried to head back the head toy
imprisons them and make sure that they
can't escape and from there all sorts of
crazy situations happen woody tries to
reconnect with his group again barbie
gets a new boyfriend with ken voiced by
michael keaton
Buzz's reprogrammed to be evil much at
the dismay of his new girlfriend Jessie
and the Toy stri to figure out what's
the best route to go stay with Andy stay
with the daycare center or some other
alternative the funny thing about Toy
Story 3 is that really this should be my
favorite it goes everywhere I wanted the
Toy Story movies to go after the second
one created such a good dilemma I said
to myself the next one should be about
what happens when Andy actually does
grow up and that's exactly what happens
it's also the darkest of the movies it
has probably some of the scariest images
and some of the most intense moments
certainly the heaviest on the drama they
continue to do the great toy jokes I
mean the stuff with Ken is hilarious all
your favorite characters are there well
most of a bo-peep sort gets insultingly
sidelined
we've lost friend
along the way Bo Peep yeah even even Bo
they asked who the bitch living on then
once again we have a legitimate threat
that does have a backstory that makes
them sort of credible so why don't I
like this one as much as I like the
other two especially when everyone else
in the world seems to regard it as a
masterpiece I don't know maybe there's
too much focus on them trying to get out
maybe the daycare center is a little too
ugly a place not fun to really be around
which I know they're taking a darker
turn but the second one sort of did too
when it was still enjoyable when I think
of this movie I think of a lot of grays
and greens and yellows and just not very
pleasant I could have used a few more
jokes and maybe not quite as much drama
well maybe if they just balanced it out
a little bit more and okay I'll address
the elephant in the room I think the
ending is corny again without giving
away too much this is the ending that
everybody cries at everyone gets
emotional for everybody sees their
childhood in this scene I'm gonna sound
like a cold-hearted bastard but I was
kind of snickering I can see a nostalgic
grown man acting this way I can see even
a little child acting this way but the
way Andy acts as a college kid I think
most of us have been that age we
remember what we were like and most of
us are not this clinging nostalgic yet
at least not to this degree don't get me
wrong we go through it we all go through
it I still can't believe I gave away all
my Ninja Turtle toys what the hell those
were alive but that's the thing I still
gave him away think about when you gave
away your toys was it really this
heartbreaking probably not that stuff
happens when you're much older and when
you're around this age you don't have as
many concerns about the past this is
more for like a midlife crisis now if
the point came where he had to give the
toys away and he paused for a second
maybe that would have been more powerful
maybe if he just gave a second look and
then decide to hand them over but good
more he goes through every toy has a
description for every single one of them
talks to them like they were individual
people what a dweeb if you knew a
college kid who did this you probably
stay the fuck away from him and with the
level of seriousness they sang it with
you probably keep on the way from your
kids too so their eyes
at the moment that I'm sure will get me
a ton of hate mail so of course you must
think I don't like this film well no I
still think it's a very very good film
in fact I actually do think it's a great
way to end a Toy Story trilogy it does
go darker it does address the moment
that was building up in the other films
it does have a very satisfactory
conclusion it's just a little indulgent
at times at least for my tastes
but it still has my favourite characters
it still has a lot of good laughs it has
surprisingly a lot of suspense and hey
it's still Toy Story and for a lot of
people this represents something that
they grew up with as children and maybe
that's why suddenly people do react the
way they do at the very end a lot of
kids were Andy's age when the first Toy
Story came out so to watch themselves
grow up and to watch the films actually
grow up with them as well
probably mirrors a lot of developments
that a lot of people in the audience
have gone through maybe in the end
that's toy story's great secret it new
just want to come out and in knew just
when to stop it reached just the right
age bracket and decided to grow up with
us and for those who didn't grow up
around the same age maybe Toy Story
brought them back to that age maybe they
hid something that not only do we all
remember but we all hold so precious and
close to us
whatever Toy Story did it did it well so
well that people are going to continue
to show it to their kids for generations
at generations it's a good series of
films to be introduced to it's a great
nostalgic series to look back on
you